uh do you play video games
I do but if I do I'm playing this [ __ ]
for like 20 minutes I can't yeah
what do you play even if I do got time I
just get bored quick yeah
I play [ __ ]
Madden
Madden Call of Duty 2K that [ __ ]
sometime you know
that's making me mad Madden's been so
trash for so long are you uh are you a
Titans fan
I know it's like Nashville's not close
to Memphis but or I mean I know it's the
same state right
so would you say you were a Titan's fan
well who's your team now
the books oh Brady Bunch
now did you just become a bucks fan
because Tom Brady's there I see it the
Brady Bunch oh yeah yeah so you're one
of those guys huh yeah I want to know
yeah you got a [ __ ] football team in
your home state like I like where's Tom
Brady at
it's a good spot I used to live there
for real oh yeah you still even say
paint St Pete is wild man it's a good
place man
yeah you're obviously a Grizzlies fan
right
yeah
okay so who do you really [ __ ] with yeah
now the way you just said that what I'm
so cool so whatever what other team do
you like
I don't like no other team like okay
who's your favorite player that's not on
the Grizzlies
it's not only
easy money
sniper Katie yeah yeah is he tapped in
slow Reaper yeah yeah I feel like he uh
he's a pretty hardcore hip-hop head no
he's a real [ __ ] yeah
you guys uh text DM
I'm gonna be on uh audit yeah I let him
do him let him do me